ce réseau est toxique alors toxiques il
était pour moi parce qu'il est et
chronophage pouvez pas savoir le thon
jaune a fait une émission il fixe
intitulé twitter rend-il fous ils et
comment il est chronophage mais il est
aussi par le jeu des algorithmes par le
jeu des algorithmes s'ils voulaient au
début twitter il ya dix ans vous aviez
votre timeline et vous aviez cd
chronologique dire que vous avez le
dernier ami il ya 4 ou 5 ans 6 ans je
sais plus ils ont changé et ils ont
organisé ça pour vous inciter à tweeté
c'est à dire que on va dire que en gros
il va y avoir 80 90 % de choses qui vous
conforte dans votre idée si vous
radicaliser puis ordi pour son jeu de
tweets qui vous agace tout ceux qui sont
entre les deux qui pourraient vous faire
éventuellement vous faire réfléchir vous
faire voilà faire bouger sûr votre
position
ceux là on les élimine parce que cela
ils vont pas si vous réfléchissez vous
grégory est assez intelligent pour faire
la différence alors en dehors donc donc
et du coup voilà où on a une espèce de
manipuler de de court j'avais comparer
ça à la cour du film ridicule de patrice
leconte ou il faut absolument humilié
quelqu'un etc
pour moi il est très pernicieux et c'est
pour ça que j'ai quitté que j'ai rejoint
le courage et les vérités et surtout les
politiques vous reliez donc en fait où
on peut faire un choix de ne pas aller
voir ces énoncés sont insultés mais non
je ne sais plus quoi est-ce qu'il faut
que faut-il l'interdire tenait autant
pas du tout alors il est rompu cela ne
alors l'animal je suis joueur but je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec ce
qui a été dit jusqu'à maintenant
l'anonymat n'est pas en cause et
justement ce que j'ai observé et ce qui
m'avait d'ailleurs cavité un des
ressorts de mon roman dérapages vous
avez eu la gentillesse de rappeler en
début d'émission c'est que en fait les
céphalées plus les plus dangereux les
anonymes pas du tout les anonymes ils
ont 4 5 follower sait rien on s'en fiche
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui anime qui
viennent vous insulter en revanche quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui vend de votre
peau et qui est demandé de faux au
piquet journalistes sur la place de
paris et ses thérapies qui vous dit vous
avez dérapé et c est puis qu'il a
cinquante mille des followers c'est pas
la même musique donc c'est pas du tout
le cas l'anonymat qu' en cause pas du
tout et je veux absolument pas revenir
là sous l'anonymat
à
[Musique]